The joe rogan experience. Well,
a little knives in the end.
It's a cat's Dick,
so he's just scooping it out of there.
Is this a woman or a man? I don't
know. It's someone who's not that fat.
Oh,
whoever the fuck this is.
If they just got on a carb free
diet for like a couple of weeks,
it's not even like, oh, not
that long of weight to lose.
I know a lady who didn't need it and got
it done. She literally didn't need it.
I don't know. I don't know her that well,
but I remember her friends saying, oh,
how much extreme discomfort she was
in because she had a where essentially
electess these tights.
Super tight compression pants everywhere
to keep all your ass fat together.
Isn't it amazing? It's so debt.
That's what I was laughing.
My ass fat loosened.
I had a hair transplant.
That was the dumbest thing I've ever
done. Feldman. That's what he did.
I was giant scar in the back of my head.
It looks like a smile.
I wonder if that's his piece of meat. My
Joe. You get like a scar from it. Yeah.
My joke was that it's like taking people
from a town where everybody's healthy
and moving them into a town
where everybody's dying.
The only ones that were left
for like the new recruits,
like the hair that was supposed
to be up there pulling out.
So where do you get it from? Like other
party it from the back of your head.
They take a strip off about now the way
they do it and a lot of places they do
it differently and do one
individual follicle at a time.
I just was scared that I was going
ball. It was like, what can you do?
And they tell you they can fix it. They're
like, oh great, I'll just get it fixed.
But it doesn't really fix it now.
Well how come that was me,
Joel Mchale, cause I remember him
from those Burger King commercials.
We had less hair than I do. I know it
all now he's got dragonball z here. Wow.
Real thick. It's almost like
more thick than they start with.
Sometimes you have a killer
transplant or is that just the guy?
Great head of hair man.
You didn't you remember the
Burger King Commercial, right?
I do. I do not. Nobody does. It was
when the office was getting popular,
not to put the American one and Burger
King at these commercials that were kind
of like the office and he was like,
the wise I can picture one vertical,
have thicker hair,
works better.
Every bald guys fucking
him as he sees more hair.
I remember people with a thick hair
follicles can get away with it.
Like my hair would have looked way better,
but I have thin hair.
The hair's themselves are thin. So if
someone has thick hair, they could,
they could have some pretty dramatic
results if it's the right kind of things.
Did you do it dirty? No, not even 30.
Yeah. What do you tell him to 30 when you,
yeah,
I think I was 28.
I just started acting on TV and I was
panicking because my hair was like
seriously falling out and I was like, this
shit, it's going quick. And I was like,
well, where's it going to go? And um,
she's just get thicker. Pubes. Well,
I was like,
how was I knew that part of the reason
why I was making money was the way I
looked.
I mean I,
I was doing stand up and I was acting
in these shows but I wasn't an ugly dude
and it helped,
you know like it was getting certain
kinds of roles like boyfriend roles.
CIC has to go through it. Yeah, you
can be panicked because you're like,
well this is how I'm making money
and I never made any money before.
So all of a sudden,
wow.
I went from being completely broke
and being a super struggling comic.
Like if I got lucky I was to make it 300
a week. Three 50 a week was a big one.
Why is that bad? Is that bad for a week?
Perfect. If you're a 25 year old guy,
which is what I was trying
to make it as a comic,
then it went from that to making fucking
shit piles of TV money and you're like,
how do I not my bag,
I'm not getting rid of this.
I to figure out a way to
keep this rolling. But if I
should just shaved my end,
I just didn't, you know, the freedom
freedom I have now, even if I hit,
grew like a thick head of hair,
I guarantee you I'd still shaved my head.
I don't want to go to a barber. I had a
really nice lady used to cut my hair too.
I loved her. She's fun, fun conversations.
But I'd have to go to war fucking
place and she'd have to like,
I wake up every four days. I go,
why? Where's your mommy of, um,
can you talk about that?
I that chilling pursuit,
but I was on some odd JB Smoove you
said this like dinner show where it'd be
like a couple of athletes and like a
couple of comics. Oh yeah. And I, I don't,
because I'm a one of the follow sports,
but these guys were just say he's a
hockey player and some football players,
how fucking which minority?
And they're talking about
all these treatments that
would get, you know, and um,
most of them,
sort of his beauty treatments for,
for rich fucking Hollywood women real.
And then they trickle down to athletes.
Wow. Cryo, that's where, I'm sorry,
I swear to God they were
talking about Cryo that way.
Like it was for fucking hot checks
cause they're kind of like a hot chicks.
The kind of athlete, right.
I can go like, oh yeah.
Then you throw your arm out. Dean
Turner, like Blue Bluer face out from
uh, steroids for arthritis.
No Way. She didn't want to be,
she wanted people to know about some
illness. You still should get less work.
So she just was not all the jokes
about how she looked like a man.
She just took all the jokes to work and
then finally came chemo, which I go like,
yeah, good for you man. If he got workout
it, cause you know, people are terrified.
Uh,
well especially me being going
from being an insanely hot woman,
I didn't know gross.
That is a change of everything.
That's a change of character.
It's a character builder guy
who was in all his money.
You find out who really liked you
the whole time, you know? Yeah.
It changes how you interface with
the world. Like a beautiful woman.
Interfaces with the world. Like the
most popular celebrity possible. Yeah.
Beautiful woman is like Tom
Cruise everywhere. She goes,
okay.